♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO TUCKER CARLSON
NEW NUMBERS, STRIKING
NUMBERS THAT HAVE NEVER BEEN
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
SO YOU HAVE HEARD THE SAME
LINE A MILLION TIMES.
IT'S REPEATED LIKE A MANTRA
BY THE LEFT DURING EVERY
DEBATE ON THE SUBJECT.
ALL IMMIGRANTS ARE
HARD-WORKING AND LAW
ABIDING.
THEY DO JOBS YOU WOULDN'T
CONSIDER DOING AND THEY DO
THEM CHEERFULLY.
THEY SACRIFICE FOR THEIR
FAMILIES IN WAYS YOU
PROBABLY DON'T.
IN FACT, AND THIS IS ALWAYS
THE LAST POINT, IT'S ALWAYS
DELIVERED WITH THE CONFIDENT
SATISFACTION OF SOMEONE
SHUTTING DOWN A DEBATE WITH
SUPERIOR DATA.
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS
VIRTUOUS THAN YOU ARE, THEY
ARE SAFER TO BE AROUND.
SUPERIORS.
BUT, WAIT, ARE WE SURE THAT
THAT IS TRUE?
ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE IN THIS
COUNTRY PRECISELY BECAUSE
THEY WERE WILLING TO BREAK
OUR IMMIGRATION LAWS REALLY
LESS LIKELY TO BREAK OTHER
KINDS OF LAWS?
IT DOESN'T MAKE A LOT OF
YET, UNTIL TODAY, STRANGELY
ENOUGH, NO ONE COULD SAY FOR
SURE WHETHER IT WAS TRUE.
BECAUSE RIVAL STATISTICS
DIDN'T SEEM TO EXIST.
OUR GOVERNMENT TRACKS PRETTY
MUCH EVERY TREND AND EVERY
PISTACHIO NUTS ARE RECALLED
EVERY YEAR TO HOW MANY FIFTH
GRADERS ARE INJURED ON SWING
SETS AND HOW MANY PEOPLE DIE
BUREAUCRAT NUMBERS CONTROL
OUR LIVES EXCEPT ON THIS
SUBJECT.
TRYING TO TRACK THE VOLUME
OF CRIME COMMITTED BY
MAYBE THEY WERE TOO
INCOMPETENT TO DO IT.
MORE LIKELY THEY DIDN'T WANT
YOU TO KNOW THE ANSWER OR TO
THINK ABOUT IT, EVEN.
IN ANY CASE, WE NOW FOR THE
FIRST TIME HAVE THE ACTUAL
NUMBERS, AND HERE THEY ARE.
COMMIT SERIOUS CRIMES THAN
AMERICANS ARE.
NONCITIZENS ACCOUNT FOR 22%,
MORE THAN A FIFTH OF ALL
FEDERAL MURDER CONVICTIONS.
18% OF FRAUD CONVICTIONS.
33% OF MONEY LAUNDERING
CONVICTIONS.
29% OF DRUG TRAFFICKING
CONVICTIONS AND 72% OF
CONVICTIONS FOR DRUG
POSSESSION.
MEANWHILE, THE NONCITIZEN
ABOUT 7%.
SO THAT IS A MASSIVELY
DISPROPORTIONATE AMOUNT OF
TIME.
LAW ABIDING AND LESS
DANGEROUS THAN AMERICANS.
THAT'S TOTALLY UNTRUE.
INDEED, IT'S THE OPPOSITE OF
THE TRUTH.
NONCITIZENS ARE MORE LIKELY
TO BE ARRESTED, CONVICTED
AND IMPRISONED FOR SERIOUS
CRIMES
THIMES
THANES
THAN PEOPLE WHO WERE BORN
HERE.
LYING TO US ABOUT THIS FOR
SO LONG THAT'S A QUESTION WE
WELL, WE WILL START TONIGHT
WITH THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE NATIONAL IMMIGRATION
FORUM AND HE JOINS US IN THE
STUDIO.
THANKS A LOT FOR COMING ON.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
>> Tucker: THIS IS A
CONVERSATION I HAVE HAD, I
DON'T KNOW, A DOZEN TIMES IN
ACTUALLY, NONCITIZENS ARE
LESS LIKELY TO COMMIT
CRIMES.
AND THEY CITE SOME KATO
STUDY.
NOW WE HAVE DEFINITIVE
NUMBERS ON THIS THAT SHOWS
NONCITIZENS ARE NOT LESS
LIKELY TO COMMIT SERIOUS
CRIMES LIKE MURDER AND FRAUD
AND DRUG TRAFFICKING BUT FAR
MORE LIKELY TO COMMIT THOSE
THIS NOW?
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
KEEPING THE NATION SECURE IN
A WAY THAT'S USING OUR
VALUABLE LAW ENFORCEMENT
RESOURCE IN THE BEST WAY.
I WILL BE THE FIRST TO TELL
YOU THAT WE ARE A NATION OF
LAWS.
AND WE ARE A NATION THAT
SHOULD BE KEEPING AMERICANS
SAFE.
>> Tucker: RIGHT.
THOSE PUBLIC SAFETY THREATS
OFF THE STREETS.
PARTICULARLY IF THEY ARE
IMMIGRANTS.
THE WAY DO YOU THAT IS THAT
YOU MAKE SURE THAT THE
IMMIGRANTS COMMUNITY CAN
ABOUT THE DIRECTION OF THE
ADMINISTRATION.
WHEN IT COMES TO IMMIGRATION
ENFORCEMENT, BECAUSE THEY
ARE ACTUALLY UNDERMINING THE
WEIRD AL CHEMY WHERE
ENFORCING BORDER LAWS MAKES
US LESS SAFE.
IF 22% OF MURDER CONVICTIONS
NONCITIZENS BUT ONLY 7% OF
THE POPULATION NONCITIZEN.
THAT SUGGESTS WE ARE LETTING
IN THE WRONG PEOPLE.
>> IT SUGGESTS WE SHOULD BE
DOING A MUCH BETTER JOB IN
TERMS OF LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
THE WAY TO DO THAT IS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITY IS IN A POSITION
TO REPORT CRIMES.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
IMMIGRANTS WHO ARE
COMMITTING THOSE CRIMES, DO
YOU KNOW WHO THE MOST LIKELY
VICTIM IS IN THE IMMIGRANT.
>> Tucker: THAT'S -- HOLD
ON, SO YOU ARE SAYING, WAIT,
HOLD ON, LET'S JUST PAUSE
AND LET THESE NUMBERS KIND
UNTIL TODAY.
22% OF ALL FEDERAL MURDER
CONVICTIONS NONCITIZENS.
33% OF MONEY LAUNDERING
CONVICTIONS NONCITIZEN.
29% DRUG TRAFFICKING.
72% OF ALL CONVICTIONS FOR
DRUG POSSESSION NONCITIZEN.
NONCITIZENS ARE FAR MORE
LIKELY TO COMMIT SERIOUS
CRIMES THAN NATIVE BORN.
CITIZENS.
AND FOREIGN BORN CITIZENS
FOR THAT MATTER.
--RARATION INTO
--RADITION INTO
--RADICAON INTO
--RADICALL INTO
--RADICALLYINTO
--RADICALLY CTO
--RADICALLY CURTAIL.
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY.
>> Tucker: NO.
NUMBERS TODAY SO WE ACTUALLY
DON'T REALLY KNOW WHERE
THESE CRIMES ARE BEING
COMMITTED.
WE DON'T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT
IT OTHER THAN.
THIS THIS IS THE FIRST HARD
THE IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY IS
THE VICTIM -- IS THE
DISPROPORTIONATE.
>> Tucker: IT DOESN'T
MATTER.
WHY ARE WE LETTING IN PEOPLE
WHO ARE MANY TIMES MORE
LIKELY TO COMMIT MURDER,
FRAUD, DRUG TRAFFICKING THAN
PEOPLE WHO ARE BORN HERE?
WHY DON'T WE THINK THROUGH
WHO WE LET IN?
DOESN'T IT SUGGEST THAT TO
YOU?
>> IT SUGGESTS TO ME THAT
OUR IMMIGRATION SYSTEM IS
FUNDAMENTALLY BROKEN.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
HERE WHO ARE UNDOCUMENTED
ARE REGISTERING FOR LEGAL
BACKGROUND CHECK, LEARNING
ENGLISH AND COMING.
>> Tucker: I GET YOU HAVE
YOUR PREEXISTING PRIORITIES.
YOU DO IT FOR A LIVING.
I RESPECT THAT THESE ARE
BRAND NEW NUMBERS.
WE DIDN'T KNOW THEM WHEN WE
WOKE UP THIS MORNING.
NOW WE DO.
THE DEBATE IS OVER.
NONCITIZENS ARE FAR MORE
LIKELY TO COMMIT CRIME THAN
CITIZENS.
WITH THAT IN MIND, DOES THAT
SHOCK YOU.
>> IT SHOCKS ME WE HAVEN'T
BEEN ADDRESSING THE PROBLEM
THE CORRECT WAY.
>> Tucker: WHY HAVE WE BEEN
SAYING THE OPPOSITE.
YOU KNOW ACCORDING TO KATO
OR THINK TANK CAN WE PAUSE
AND SAY WE WERE TOTALLY
WRONG ABOUT WHAT WE HAVE
BEEN SAYING?
>> THE PROBLEM HERE IS WE
WANT TO GET VIOLENT
CRIMINALS OFF THE STREET,
CORRECT?
>> Tucker: WE DON'T WANT
WHY ARE WE MAKING LAW
ENFORCEMENT DEAL WITH THESE
PEOPLE?
WHY DON'T WE STOP IT AT THE
BORDER AND THEN WE DON'T
HAVE TO PUT OUR POLICE AND
CITIZENS AT RISK?
>> I THINK THAT'S A GREAT
IDEA.
THE WAY DO YOU THAT IS THAT
YOU MAKE SURE YOU HAVE A
FUNCTIONING LEGAL
IMMIGRATION SYSTEM AND A
PROCESS FOR PEOPLE TO GO
THROUGH.
THE ONLY PEOPLE WHO ARE
HIDING FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT.
>> Tucker: DON'T WE BRING IN
MORE THAN A MILLION PEOPLE
LEGALLY EVERY YEAR?
>> IT'S CLEARLY OUT OF
WHACK.
WE ARE ALSO A MUCH BIGGER
ACTUALLY NOT A BIGGER
COUNTRY.
>> OUR WORKFORCE IS ACTUALLY
MUCH MORE DYNAMIC.
>> Tucker: MAYBE.
LEAVING THE ECONOMICS ASIDE.
THAT'S ANOTHER SHOW, ANOTHER
DEBATE.
I JUST WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT ONE OF THE CORE
OPERATING ASSUMPTIONS THAT
WE HAVE HAD FOR YEARS, AND I
HAVE BEEN AT THE CENTER OF
THIS, WAS WRONG.
NOT JUST WRONG BUT TOTALLY
WRONG.
IT WAS A LIE DOES THAT MAKE
YOU REASSESS WHAT YOU
HOW DO WE SOLVE THE PROBLEM?
IF YOU WANT TO QUIBBLE ABOUT
STATISTICS YOU SHOULD BRING
SOMEBODY FROM KATO.
>> IT'S NOT QUIBBLING LING.
WHAT WE CLAIM IS THE VERY
OPPOSITE OF THE TRUTH.
>> I WANT TO FOCUS ON
SOLVING PROBLEMS.
TUCKER.
ONLY WAY YOU CAN DO THAT IS
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE CRIMES
THEY COMMIT IS BEING
REPORTED BY THE VICTIMS.
IF THE VICTIM IS AN
IMMIGRANT WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE.
>> Tucker: CLEARLY SOMEONE
IS REPORTING THESE CRIMES.
WE DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM WITH
THAT BECAUSE, AGAIN, THE --
I MEAN, WE HAVE
DISPROPORTIONATELY BIG
NUMBERS HERE.
MY QUESTION IS WHY DO YOU
THINK NONCITIZENS ARE
COMMITTING CRIMES AT FAR
GREATER RATE THAN AMERICANS
ARE?
>> I THINK WE HAVE GOT TO
MAKE SURE THAT INDIVIDUALS
COMING TO THE COUNTRY DRY
PROPERLY VETTED.
THEY ARE GOING THROUGH THE
PROCESS THEY NEED TO.
>> Tucker: YOU ADMIT THEY
>> FOLKS HERE UNDOCUMENTED
WE NEED TO REQUIRE THEY PASS
VIOLENT THREAT TO OUR PUBLIC
SAFETY, THEY ARE THE ONES
HIDING.
PUBLIC KIND OF WANTS THAT
WHAT'S YOUR ARGUE.
AGAINST THAT EXACTLY?
BORDER.
YOU WANT TO FOCUS WHERE THE
PROBLEM IS THE MAJORITY OF
DRUGS MONEY, SMUGGLED PORTS
OF ENTRY.
>> Tucker: THESE ARE NOT
DRUGS AND GUNS THOOVMENT
>> THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WOULDN'T HELP AT ALL BECAUSE
THE RISK IS ON THE BORDER.
THERE WAS THIS RISK UNTIL
ABOUT TWO HOURS AGO.
MAYBE WE SHOULD PAUSE AND